her predecessor Nadine Doris wasn't
afraid to Fan the culture War Flames now
Michelle Jonathan the 11th conservative
culture secretary in 12 years is laying
the foundations of what she intends to
do with the role nice to meet you
wanting more of this shepparton set to
be the second biggest studio in the
world long-term leases signed with both
Netflix and Prime video
this is clearly a success story few
Industries have bounced back quite so
emphatically post-pandemic but strictly
speaking it isn't really film that needs
government assurances right now it's the
British TV broadcasters that are
desperate for some clarity
whereas Doris butted heads with the BBC
signaling her intention to abolish the
license fee now a different tone I think
the BBC is a fantastic institution we do
need to make on the BBC them sustainable
in the long term it's a National Asset
we need to inject fairness and choice
into the system that we pick but we will
make any decisions informed by evidence
a decision on whether plans to privatize
Channel 4 might be ditched expected in
the upcoming Media bill I'm working very
closely with Channel 4 on this but we've
been absolutely clear that we've been
reviewing the business case and that was
one of my priorities when I entered the
the department
before that the Online safety Bill back
before parliament in just over a week
with changes taking a common sense
approach apparently to what's deemed to
be harmful the tap that I have taken is
to make sure that we we do protect
children we Safeguard them we're also
rebalancing some of that freedom of
choice for adults and you'll see the the
specific changes in the direction of
travel when it comes to downtime and
watching TV subtle swipe at Matt
Hancock's stint in the jungle it's not
the decision I would make because I want
to focus on my constituents and being as
accessible as possible but that's up to
him
if arts and culture were at times
casualties of an ideological war under
her predecessor perhaps now the economic
importance of cementing good
relationships coming to the fore Katie
Spencer Sky News